- You just made a generalization.
We went from spicy to knowing how to cook.
I feel like Nigerians know how to cook.
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
(upbeat guitar and bongo music)
- I eat it probably once or twice a year.
- I had rice last week.
- This has always been my favorite dish.
- I don't know how to make
it, but I know how to eat it.
- I hope today I like
eat something and it like
just goes, mmm, this is home.
- I'm wondering if Nigerian
rice will be so different
that I will be able to
automatically be like,
no, this is not it.
- Ooh, I'm hungry.
- Aren't plantains like fried bananas?
- I really am about to smell it though.
- This one smells a bit more like home.
- This already tastes amazing,
so I'm just gonna go ahead
and say that this is Nigerian.
(buzzer buzzes)
I can taste the love of my
ancestors running through this.
- Ghana, Nigeria.
(buzzer buzzes)
- I'll try it one more time.
- This is Ghanaian right here.
(buzzer buzzes)
- You sure?
- Yeah man, this has got
that kick and this doesn't.
- You feel focused.
- I'm trying to--
Yeah.
(laughter)
- This one.
- This is weak sauce
this is Nigerian right here.
- Oh, that's right.
- This has gotta be Ghanaian
- If you do not stand
firm in your decision--
- I'll take this as the Nigerian rice
and this will be the Ghanaian rice.
(bell chimes)
- How does it make you
feel about this beef
that you just ate?
- Nigerians always got to one up.
- Everybody makes jollof
rice differently, okay?
I'm just gonna let you
know that 'cause my mom
and my aunt's jollof rice is the bomb.com.
- Still feel like the way
the recipe is passed down
and whatnot, everybody's
taste buds and the way that
they flavor it is different,
but hey, maybe it's just
like everybody's jollof is different.
- Both Nigerian jollof rice
and Ghanaian jollof rice is good.
So we did good?
- Yeah, we did.
- It was between Ghana
- and Nigeria.
- And Nigeria.
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)